so I've played armored Core 6 and long
story short the game is just good
I've never felt so privileged to show
off a game before I know I'm biased
since I have this Channel and everything
but the game is just so special it marks
the point where an old franchise is
coming back to life it represents a
genre that so many new people will get
to try for the first time and yet it's
still undeniably a from software game
with so many familiar Hallmarks of their
modern game design but if you are a
newcomer to the series you might be
thinking that this combat and UI is
overwhelming and you're right it is but
trust me when I say that it's worth
taking the time to understand it all so
let's start at the beginning with the
very first mission of almond core 6.
the game starts with you being sent to
infiltrate the planet Rubicon 3.
but it doesn't exactly go according to
plan
clearly the rubiconians don't want
anyone entering the airspace
and it wouldn't be a fromsoft game if
you didn't start the game half dead
already complete
grid 1
once off Target but within permissible
range
the man speaking here is your Handler
Walter and you are his Hound trained to
follow his every command time to fly 621
with this we're shot closer to where we
were supposed to be if we get our hands
on rubicon's Coral
we'll make a killing plenty for a Merc
with a fried brain like you to buy their
life back
foreign
[Music]
mercenary license
or illegals here you'll need ID to
operate
this is the mech you start the game with
it has an assault rifle a laser blade
and multi-lock missiles
in this next section I'll try to break
down how the game plays
picking up signals from AC Rex
what I'm doing now is called an assault
boost it's the most efficient way to
cover great distances it's also really
really good in combat you can even Dodge
during it like this
if you come to a stop while grounded you
will walk like this but gliding with
your boosters is generally better and
this is your quick boost your Dodge and
then there's one button to jump and
Ascend all of this requires energy which
recovers really rapidly while you're
grounded
this marks the first AC wreck that we've
found
[Music]
this one's already expired
keep looking
so there are multiple Parts through this
huge City and it's swarming with enemies
what
breathing down our
thanks to the dialogue in this game
missions are really engaging either
Walters telling you something or you're
eavesdropping on enemies or your foes
are freaking out because they have to
fight you it's fun
let's talk missiles by default all
missiles go to a single Target like this
but if you hold down the fire button you
can launch at multiple enemies instead
you're going to be outnumbered a lot in
armored Core so staying mobile and
constantly firing off missiles is just a
good way to play
it I overcome multiple enemies here by
firing missiles and by making use of
line of sight to avoid enemies while I
reload
yeah
right shelter ammunition
[Music]
there's one last AC rack to find and
this is the pilot whose Legacy you
pillage to obtain your new name that's
it try accessing the rack perhaps
unsurprisingly it's time to prepare for
a boss fight so as you can see I've
toggled on my target assist shown here
this is an automatic hard lock mode
that's great for focusing on a single
enemy
[Music]
it's your typical early from soft boss
and an enemy that you probably won't be
able to defeat unless you're comfortable
with the fundamentals of the game
you need to always keep moving to avoid
enemy fire get hit too many times and
your stability will break watch and
listen for warning signs try to stay
close and use your blade use the
environment to block enemy attacks and
while all of this is going on you need
to make sure that you're using all four
of your weapons efficiently so that you
can break through enemy defenses and
deal massive damage
[Music]
registration number rb23
call sign Raven authentication complete
moving Mia status restoring access
privileges
the mercenary support system
welcome back Raven
we've played previous AC games you know
how good it feels to hear that
after you've listened to all of your new
messages you'll enter this the garage
here you can customize your AC you can
sell its old Parts you can buy new parts
and inevitably you'll realize that the
new parts are too heavy for your legs so
you buy new legs and on and on it goes
you can get lost in a sea of complex
cost benefit analysis here or you can
kind of just buy the biggest gun you can
carry and remember that bread number's
bad but blue numbers good and get by
that way instead whatever your approach
it's surprisingly fun once you get a
feel for what every part does
but that's not all you can do in the
garage you can also practice in the
training simulator you can earn upgrades
in the arena and you can replay old
missions and then when you're ready you
can sortie onto your next mission
except I can't show you the next mission
I actually can't show you the next four
missions I can only show you 20 minutes
of footage from missions one six seven
eight and eleven so please forgive me
for all of the screenshots that I've
been showing you to save time here
anyway over the course of the next four
missions that I can't show you I worked
my way towards constructing an AC design
that I call Black Flint this build had
gotten me through previous armored Core
games so I figured that it would be able
to get me through this game as well
I love this build it basically uses two
sets of small missiles to break open
enemy defenses which often enables me to
land direct hits with the Bazooka and
assault rifle this build was more than
enough to take me past the final boss
that we were allowed to fight in Mission
11. the end but not really because
simply beating missions isn't really the
end game in armored Core the real test
of your skill is replaying those
missions and attempting to achieve a
perfect S rank in them I felt like there
was a chance that I might unlock
something cool if i s ranked a few
missions so I gave it a shot to better
my chances of this I decided to quickly
create a set of four diverse builds that
I thought might be better suited to each
Mission so I made a tank build for
Mission 6 a flying quadruped for mission
7 a lightweight melee build for Mission
8 and a heavy energy weapon biped for
mission 11. let me take you through each
Mission with these builds starting with
mission 6.
in true armored Core fashion each
Mission starts with a briefing
good sit your ass down and listen
I can't show all of this but basically
Balaam is one of the big corporations
that wants to break through the locals
defenses here on Rubicon and for this
task they've enlisted two of their own
ACS as well as you an independent
mercenary main system activating combat
mode
to why we're here
climb the wall
this Mission does a great job of
characterizing balaam's red gun group
your teammate gun five iguasu talks down
to you constantly you can tell he really
hates that you're just freelancing for
the highest bidder whereas he's actually
proud to be one
red guns
as I fight this enemy AC I need to talk
about these tread legs that I'm equipped
with so they really change how the game
feels to play it feels more like driving
around in a vehicle with these and
there's an incredible sense of momentum
and weight to everything which then
comes in handy whenever you decide to
over boost charge into enemies like this
what's more tank and quad legs absorb
recoil from your weapons meaning you can
stay mobile while firing heavy weaponry
then I destroyed the dam I completed the
mission and even though I thought I
played perfectly I only received an a
rank so I attempted to S rank this
mission one more time with this a
reverse jointed dual machine gunner I
danced circles around my enemies and I
ignored the AC fight at the end and
simply focused on blowing up the dam as
fast as possible instead
with this I finally received my S rank
the red guns are going to be first over
the wall
have fun watching from the sidelines
so Mission 6 was handed to you by Balaam
Industries but in mission 7 another
Corporation Called archibus has tasked
you with taking on The Strider a mobile
resource base that has been extensively
weaponized by the Rubicon Liberation
Front to destroy this thing you need to
take out the eye a giant Laser cannon
shielded by four main generators these
are your first four targets that is if
you can get close enough without the eye
incinerating you
[Music]
sheer scale of this enemy is absolutely
staggering previous games have had arms
forts like this before but they've never
looked this good
take out one of its legs
in the Heights later
as you climb you can hear the Strider
Personnel progressively get more and
more panicked they literally try to
detach parts of the Strider to try and
get rid of you but it's no use
in my S rank attempt for this Mission I
made this energy weapon quadruped build
the unique thing about quadrupeds in
this game is that if you tap the jump
button while you're Airborne you can
hover in place indefinitely it probably
goes without saying that yeah this was
extremely useful in this Mission just
for some perspective here's what I
looked like on my first attempt
on for a while
but even then I still managed to destroy
all four generators and
destroy the eye that looks like all that
energy
with the Strider down archivists are
impressed with you to say the least this
gets a foot in the door for your Handler
to ask for a spot on operation wall
clock
[Music]
operation wall climber is epic and scale
not because you're taking out a large
enemy or anything but because it's a
long mission
first you have to find a way to get
behind two Gatling cannons defending the
city then you have to break through the
city itself all while avoiding fire from
the 16 or so snipers that are positioned
on the wall
boxing
if you remember in Mission 6 the red
guns were bragging that they'd be the
first over the war but if you take the
time to explore the city here you'll
find the wreck of Gun 4 Volta your red
gun teammate dead in the streets I'm not
sure what killed him but the first real
challenge for you is to
defeatrapod Mt who is tucked underneath
the walls main gate
these things are just so much fun to
fight and my build here actually excels
at one-on-one combat it has dual
handguns and missiles to break the
enemy's guard and the pile driver which
you have to pull out of the weapon Bay
at just the right moment
and then after making your way all the
way up and through the wall it's time to
face the final boss
one of the infamous Handler Walter
sounds interesting
ready to climb the wall
[Music]
that heavy mobile
this boss is easy enough in the first
phase when you have a co-op partner but
it's extremely difficult in the second
phase when your partner leaves
you like this but you'll have to finish
without me
without V4 Rusty on my side I failed my
s-rank attempt against this mission
when you fail a mission in armored Core
6 you don't always have to start from
the beginning usually you'll have
unlocked a checkpoint and can just
reattempt the part where you died with
replenished Health healing and
ammunition what's more you're actually
able to switch up your assembly Mid
Mission as well so when I failed in my
first playthrough on this boss I simply
switched to double Bazookas and kept the
Juggernaut staggered almost indefinitely
so yeah checkpoints are a very powerful
tool and honestly I think the game's
difficulty is designed around you
needing to make use of checkpoints
checkpoints are what give from software
the design space to create long missions
and difficult encounters within those
missions but naturally if you die and
use a checkpoint then you're not going
to get an S rank for the mission so when
I failed my S rank attempt I simply
switched to double Bazookas again and
overcame the mission that way instead
might as well finish the mission and
claim those extra credits right
[Music]
the last mission I can show is Mission
11 and it's another long one
regulated the underground flow of course
now it serves to monitor the dormant
veins
the first part of the mission involves
fighting your way through two fields of
enemies who have long-ranged weaponry
who are they with
we can look into that later engagement
later there's a one-on-one fight against
an enemy AC named Sula who clearly has a
history with your Handler
your incorrigible Handler Walter
how many of your dogs Must Die kill
before you learn
sorry for you I really do you may have
survived any longer
mercenario survived first gen
augmentation
[Music]
and finally there's a boss battle a
bullet hell against the autonomous craft
named baltius
[Music]
between the missiles the shotgun the
assault armor and the flamethrower this
enemy has an insane moveset the way I
overcame this on my first playthrough
was by pivoting to dual assault rifles
so that I could just mindlessly hold my
fire buttons down and focus on
predicting and dodging its attacks
instead and that worked just
and for my S rank attempt I created
Samus a plasma weapon build with dual
pulse guns a laser cannon and a shield
and it was awful or maybe I was awful
I'm not sure I had some really cool
moments but between dodging and flying
and using my shield and charging my
Cannon and managing the overheat on my
pulse guns I think piloting this build
was just Way Beyond me at the time and I
got hit a lot so yeah even with the
checkpoint system the game is tough and
while I'm proud of the S ranks that I
did achieve I had no chance of s ranking
any of the longer missions with the
limited time that I had because think
about it 2s rank a longer Mission you
need to conceive of one build that can
overcome many different encounters all
without running out of healing or
Ammunition by the end of the mission and
that's really challenging and I'm
looking forward to attempting that come
August 25th anyway so I've used up just
about all of the unique footage that I
have to show you today but I still have
more to reveal so if you want to stick
around I'd like to go over a bunch of
game mechanics that I haven't mentioned
yet and at the end I'll also share some
more deeper personal thoughts about the
game along with some details that I
learned from an interview with the
game's lead producer and director
so do you remember when I fought an
enemy AC back in Mission 6. his name was
index Dunham and his was an optional AC
fight where he kind of just overwhelm
him with two teammates so this fight
with an enemy AC is actually optional in
this Mission but it's still absolutely
worth doing at least once because you
see this little icon here that's a
combat log marker it's a resource for
something called log hunt which rewards
you with new parts for handing in combat
logs and Rising through the ranks it's
very cool you can also actually rematch
index Dunham and a lot of other AC
fights too for that matter in the arena
in glorious simulated 1v1 combat which I
don't think I'm allowed to show you but
I can show you these menu screens from
the garage where it reveals that you are
rewarded for the fights with credits
seen here but more importantly with OST
chips as well OST stands for operating
system tuning which is another menu
that's also accessible in the garage and
it's here that you can spend your OS
chips that you earned from the arena
across four different categories first
our system unlocks which give you new
Baseline abilities some of these like
the Boost kick and the weapons Bay I'd
argue are almost essential boost kick
lets you press your assault boost button
at the end again to deal huge impact to
enemies like this and the weapon Bay
lets you equip arm weapons to your
shoulders note that you can't fire These
shouldered Arm weapons at all times like
you can with regular shoulder weapons
instead you have to switch to them
manually and then fire them with your
arm button the next category are core
expansions which are these special
offensive or defensive abilities so I
experimented with a few I used assault
armor which does huge AOE like this
I used pulse protection which puts a
barrier in place like this which was
really cool and I tried terminal armor
as well which will keep you alive at one
AP in a situation where you usually
would have died
finally there are attack control and
damage control categories which simply
increase the percentage of damage you
can deal or the amount of damage you can
heal or they reduce a percentage of the
damage you can take so upgrading your
operating system is a way to straight up
make your AC a bit stronger or a bit
more versatile and this is in contrast
to the general customization process
where you go into the garage and every
part is balanced by being strong in some
ways but weaker in others
next I want to talk about energy weapons
energy weapons do not work like they did
in previous games back then they
required a piece of your actual energy
bar to Fire and now it seems the gimmick
is that energy weapons will overheat if
you fire them too quickly so they don't
reload in the conventional sense which
means you have the option to either fire
them until they overheat or to use them
sparingly to prevent them from
overheating additionally it seems like
energy weapons can also be used to
cancel out energy defenses of the same
type so pulse energy weapons will do way
better against pulse defenses it seems
finally let's talk lock on so lock-on is
actually automatic meaning as soon as an
enemy is close enough and in your sights
your fire control system will Target
them and
as mentioned before there's a soft lock
state where you have more free movement
and there's also a hard lock State
called Target assist where your
character and your camera will perfectly
follow the enemy to my knowledge and
after reviewing all of my footage this
hard lock cannot be broken I'm pretty
sure and your AC will automatically
quick turn to perfectly face your hard
locked Target at all times so Target
assist is very powerful and it's game
defining honestly however you might have
noticed that a lot of the time I played
with softblock and I moved my camera
manually with the right thumbstick
instead now I was pretty comfortable
playing in this manner because that's
how previous armored Core games play and
I've played a lot of them so it felt
more second nature to me and playing in
this manner does give you some benefits
your motion is a bit more free and
whichever enemy is closest to the center
of your screen will be targeted so you
have more control over who you're firing
at which is especially useful when
you're surrounded by enemies however
there is a downside to moving your
camera manually with the right stick and
some of you might be able to guess what
it is it's that your thumb isn't free
anymore to press the face buttons that
are very required for dodging and
ascending and you can't really claw grip
because remember your pointer and middle
fingers are on all four of the weapon
triggers so you can't really use those
so if you want to play soft locked and
control your camera with your thumb it
essentially means that your thumb will
have to Dart over and tap the buttons
for Dodge and flight while you're also
controlling the camera which can be done
but you have to stop controlling the
camera for a moment to do so
therefore I think most people will
naturally just gravitate towards playing
with Target assist turned on most of the
time so that they can be hard locked to
enemies instead and not really have to
worry about the camera
yes this means giving up a bit of
control and aim but it frees your thumb
for dodging and flying and I think those
things are generally much more important
speaking of aiming let's talk about the
FCS part the FCS part essentially
determines how accurate your aim is and
in this game you see that little reticle
trailing the Enemy Within my lock-on
that reticle is not always on point with
the Enemy at certain ranges it will
waver or it will trail behind the enemy
and that means you'll miss so each FCS
part has three main variables it's close
range assist its medium range assist and
its long range assist basically these
values determine how good your FCS will
be when tracking enemies at these ranges
so you have to think very critically
about what sort of weapons you're
wielding when you make a build and you
also have to consider your FCS when
you're thinking about how close you
should be to enemies when you engage
them FCS Parts also determine the time
it takes for your missiles to lock onto
enemies and it also determines how long
it takes to acquire a multi-lock on
multiple enemies finally I'd like to
give some more personal thoughts on the
game first the story it's hard to get
this point across with limited footage
but as Missions play out and you're
slowly introduced to all the characters
and corporations who also have a lot of
character you really start to feel small
like you're some small piece of the
puzzle within your Handler's plans who
is himself a small piece of a larger
corporations plans who are all a small
part of this huge War over a resource
that is unfolding on Rubicon and that
feels like a very armored Core vibe to
me and I'm in love with the vibe of this
game and the amazing soundtrack also
plays a huge part in that as well in
terms of endings to this story I can
confirm that the game will have multiple
and from my interview with director Yama
murasan and Lead producer ogurusan it
sounds like endings will work a lot like
they did in the fourth generation of
armored Core where New Missions will be
revealed in New Game Plus and those
missions can be used to take you towards
different endings I loved the
replayability this brought to Generation
4 and the thought of having New Game
Plus with unique content and enemies not
just being more difficult is a really
great thing in any of from software's
games I think so I love to see that next
let's talk gameplay so I could talk for
an hour on this point but what I really
want to try and convey to you most is
that the movement in this game feels
really really good and it all comes down
to the leg types for example when you're
piloting a reverse joint leg build you
feel like your legs can just claw into
the ground and fling you off to the side
or high up into the air and
when you throw on a pair of tank treads
you really feel like you're driving a
heavy vehicle with weight and momentum
the direction you're facing matters a
lot while you're driving and then if you
want a feeling of weightlessness to
contrast that I guess you can opt for
Quad legs and rain down Death from Above
and have virtually no recoil I don't
know of many games that let you
fundamentally change the way your
character controls and the fact that it
goes deeper in the garage is also
amazing you have so much control over so
many variables of your movements and
abilities because the expanded stat
screens are back and all of this just
makes it so much fun playing with
different builds and the game will have
a ton of replayability because of this
fact next considering the recent success
of Elden ring a natural question a lot
of people are going to have is Will
Elden ring fans enjoy armored Core sex
and yes I think they will because while
this is a very different genre of game
it's also the first armored Core to have
a lot of things in common with souls for
example armored Core 6 now has a
completely decoupled camera your Mech
has fast turning speeds you can heal
there are checkpoints bosses have
heavily telegraphed attacks there's a
visual stagger system a timed block
system and a hard lock as well and
before anyone says yes I know that other
games have these things but armored Core
traditionally has not had those things
so the fact that from software developed
Elden ring and now armored Core and the
fact that I'm talking to a community of
souls fans means it's fair to draw a
comparison to souls in this case I think
and also I know that a lot of people did
not expect these things to be quite so
present when armored Core 6 was first
announced but they are here now and it
absolutely makes the game more
accessible for Souls fans and any modern
gamer in general also but what I'm
really happy about is that it still
feels a lot like an armored Core game
even with all of those things and most
importantly it's shaping up to just be a
good game with those things and I think
that's all most people care about this
is just yet another familiar
generational shift in the gameplay of
armored Core and I'm here for it
personally all that said I do you know
naturally have some concerns about the
game these aren't like terrible problems
or anything it's more like these are
things that I'm not really sure how from
software are going to handle first and
foremost there's PVP so 1v1 PVP in
armored Core has traditionally been a
about getting outside of your opponent's
sights and out maneuvering them but with
the way that Target assist Works in
armored Core sex I don't really see a
way that you can outplay people in this
manner anymore because unless there's a
way to break hard lock and I don't think
there is you're just going to be stuck
in their sights the entire time so I
actually got the chance to ask
yamamura-san the game's director about
how skill expression in PvP would work
with hard lock being a thing and he
replied with quite a few insights so
first he stated that Target assist
actually forces you to move and fight
with a certain angle of attack so it's
possible that soft lock could help you
with your evasion He also mentioned that
flying over the top of enemies might
help to prevent you from getting hard
locked now I don't think this would
really apply in 1v1 fights but in fights
with multiple people being above them
could absolutely make them less aware of
you so that's an interesting observation
additionally he says that in fights you
have to consider enemy stagger meters
and consider your own as well so the way
that you fire weapons to build up
stagger and then make use of exposed
defenses plays a role in skill
expression as well and you won't often
just get away with firing all your
weapons at once and then there's also
the need to maintain optimal distance
which plays a part in your accuracy and
dealing the right amount of damage
therefore both players will be sort of
maneuvering to maintain their own
personal ideal distance at all times and
then there's just timing in general
which is also very important to dodge
enemy fire and you obviously have to
time your own attacks as well so that
they land lastly we've only just learned
that armored Core 6 will feature six
player multiplayer and I will say I
think target lock this hard lock will be
way less impactful in 2v2 or 3v3 combat
as those game modes will just have so
much going on and honing in on one
player should matter a little bit less
but then another reason I'm curious
about PVP is I think it's just going to
be really difficult for from software to
properly balance the fact that you can
fire four weapons at once in this game
so when I asked yamamura's son about the
biggest challenges that they faced When
developing armored Core he answered that
balancing weapons was a key focus and
challenge for him and the team and I can
see why because in a lot of games you
know naturally there are overpowered
weapons it's inevitable but remember ac6
is kind of unique in that you can fire
four of those weapons at once so if
you're firing four overpowered weapons
at once just think about how much that
exacerbates any potential power
imbalance and in this online age with
people like me who are going to
naturally talk about and recommend some
overpowered weapons especially in PvP
that could be an issue so I think from
software will absolutely have their work
cut out for them in balancing this game
after release and I think to be the best
experience possible this game is going
to need more high quality balance
patches than they usually put out but
I'm sure they're aware of this
so in terms of difficulty just in the
general game encounters definitely seem
hard enough especially when you sort of
get past the beginning of the game so
don't worry about that my limited
footage naturally kind of shows my best
moments but
you should know I struggled a good
amount at times trust me checkpoints
make difficulty less inconvenient for
sure
but they don't reduce the difficulty of
individual encounters if that makes
sense they actually enable from software
to make them harder individual
encounters what I do think might be a
bit overpowered about checkpoints is the
ability to switch up your max assembly
halfway through a mission as a fan of
the older games I was a fan of not being
able to change your Mac and just
committing to whatever build you bring
in and I think changing your Mech is a
little bit immersion breaking and I
think it might also risk being a little
bit too forgiving especially for players
that understand how to build already but
it might be too early to say and I could
absolutely change my mind on that the
last thing I want to talk about is debt
so in previous games I also really loved
the threat of going into debt by playing
badly and losing credits that was a part
of the thrill really but going into debt
is not going to be a thing in armored
Core 6. so they've confirmed that I also
want to note that ac6 seems to be
extremely generous with the credits that
it gives you not only that it is very
easy to replay missions and you can also
sell parts for the same price that you
buy them at so you are naturally going
to have a lot of credits and that is by
Design you can tell I asked yamamura-san
about this and he said that from
software felt that having too much debt
might dampen the fun of the assembly
aspect and since the assembly aspect is
like the main part of this game and it's
also the most potentially off-putting
part of the game to new players I can
see why they got rid of debt the benefit
to having more credits is that you can
buy more parts and experiment with
things and just have more parts on hand
to switch to in these Mid Mission
checkpoints which is also a big thing as
well but do you know what else
yamamura-san said in response to this
question he admitted that he too was a
big fan of the debt that you could
accrue in previous games and even though
that was a punishing system he said that
he liked the feeling it gave that sense
of a severe oppressive mercenary
lifestyle and so the last point I'll
leave you on is what he said right after
this he said that if they have some nice
ideas in-house they might try to revisit
the concept of debt in some form in the
future
so fires of Rubicon sequel confirmed
probably too early to say for sure but I
know that employees of from software
have a really soft spot in their hearts
for this franchise and I really really
hope that fires of Rubicon resonates
with people so that they get the green
light to make more of these games
especially if it means that from
software might start reintroducing some
of the more hardcore more traditional
elements of armored Core I know that
these things can be off-putting to
newcomers to the franchise so I'm not
surprised that a lot of them are gone
but it would be so cool if they you know
got you familiar with the game with
fires of Rubicon and then reintroduced
some of those things I think that would
be fantastic if you're curious what
those traditional armored Core elements
are then please consider watching my
video where I play through every single
prior armored Core game or come and ask
me in real time because I should be
currently live on Twitch right now
attempting to answer everyone's
questions about my time with armored
Core 6. other than that thank you for
listening to me ramble subscribe and be
sure to switch on the Bell notifications
so you don't miss new armored Core
videos and I'll see you in the next one
[Music]
thank you